bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 14 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre information locale
entouré de nos invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition le centre géré handicap
en danger le pôle gérontologique
implantée depuis 2009 à manier hameau
est en déficit
la structure risque de fermer
définitivement troisième devient l'un
des plus grands campus audiovisuel
d'europe après trois ans de travaux
l'école de saint quentin en yvelines a
inauguré un nouveau bâtiment avec un
studio radio un renouvellement pour
l'établissement stéphane lamy
responsable de la filière cinéma et
françois richer directeur communication
nous en parlerons
enfin les joyeux urbains ont 20 ans le
groupe fondé à trappes en 1994 se lance
dans une tournée anniversaire
première date à rambouillet là où ils
ont commencé nous les avons rencontrés
et enfin cette première information pour
commencer notre journal technocentre
renault a été perquisitionné jeudi
dernier chez le constructeur automobile
a confirmé que les services de la
répression des fraudes avait procédé à
des perquisitions sur plusieurs de ces
sites dont celui de guyancourt ces
perquisitions ont eu lieu dans le cadre
des investigations voulu par le
gouvernement après le scandale des
moteurs diesel truqués de volkswagen la
direction générale de la concurrence de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes s'est également rendu au siège
social du groupe
le constructeur assure néanmoins que les
tests réalisés à la demande de la
ministre de l'ecologie ségolène royal
n'avait pas détecté de logiciels
truqueur et de grands projets pour
plaisir c'est ce qu'a annoncé joséphine
coleman ce berger la mère de plaisir a
profité de la cérémonie des voeux de
2016 hier soir pour évoquer les nouveaux
projets pour la ville
alors entre autres il sera question de
continuer la réhabilitation du centre
bourg du vally bout le silo devrait être
prochainement détruit et le centre
commercial requalifier alors qu'un
nouveau projet de centre commercial
openskies va voir le jour on écoute tout
chanter des précisions de joséphine
coltman berger écouter ça fait des
années qu'on attend ce projet est
effectivement là les permis contre
ça y est il est signé donc on espère
bien que les travaux démarrent dans
quelques mois et que l'on puisse enfin
voir cette zone
ce transfert met complètement sa vraie
plus parce que c'est une zone qui est en
friche
aujourd'hui et c'est un endroit qui
méritent véritablement qu'on mette en
place quelque chose de qualitatif alors
on attend des commerces bien sûr mais on
attend surtout les cinémas et on attend
bien sûr les restaurants un vrai lieu de
vie et je vous le disais en titre le
centre géré handicap est en danger le
pôle gérontologique implantée depuis
2009 au domaine du mes rentes et à magny
les hameaux affiche un déficit de 40
mille euros une dette liée à des retards
de loyers conséquence la structure
pourrait ferme et définitif
définitivement pardon d'ici le mois de
juin
regardez ce reportage de mickaël hay et
demi d'euros et six molière
le pôle gérondi cas pourrait fermer ses
portes courant 2016 la structure
gérontologique situe à magny les hameaux
fait face à des difficultés financières
le centre spécialisé dans l'aide aux
personnes en perte d'autonomie affiche
un déficit de 40 mille euros la raison
le loyer demandé par saint quentin en
yvelines au propriétaire des lieux
seraient trop élevés ce loyer donc
correspond quelque sorte un loyer donc
pour une structure marchande des gens
qui effectivement font un travail qui
dans lequel ils gagnent beaucoup
d'argent
ici nous sommes dans une structure
sociale effectivement donc on gagne pas
d'argent
aujourd'hui la situation est compliquée
d'autant que certains partenaires se
retire donc là l'effort qui va être
porté par l'agglomération
da c'est tout simplement de dire que on
va essayer de trouver un nouveau loyer
pour que tous ceux qui puis qu'il
souhaite rester dans gironde et gap puis
ceux de fermer aux conditions que nous
avons fixés si aucun accord n'est trouvé
le centre pourrait fermer ses portes au
mois de juin
sept postes seront alors supprimer une
vingtaine de patients devront trouver
une nouvelle structure d'accueil
c'est inhumain je dirais franchement
c'est inhumain
alors qu'on ne réussit qui est magique
qui correspond donc à quelque chose qui
était donc vécu et qui reconnut reconnu
je me battrai pour que ça ne ferme pas
une réunion pourrait être programmé dans
les prochaines semaines entre les mains
de gérer handicapés les responsables de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise la
cité des métiers attrape se renouvelle
fermé depuis des bleus début de mois de
janvier elle est en pleine
réorganisation un nouveau directeur jean
pierre lefebvre élus d'elancourt au
développement économique et conseiller
communautaire a été nommé à sa tête la
cité des métiers n'est plus lié à la
maison de l'entreprise jean michel
fourgous second vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique et des finances
nous explique ces changements écoutez le
il ya une chute de 50% du fait de
l'échec économique aujourd'hui bien sûr
du gouvernement il ya une chute des
recettes donc baisse de 50% des moyens
la maison de l'emploi il n'y a pas le
choix on l'arrête comme tout comme
beaucoup de maisons l'on peut en france
par contre on garde les missions
essentielles par rapport à nos objectifs
de développement économique emploi la
cité des métiers elle réouvrira bien fin
février écouter quand vous coupez une
structure et des contraintes juridiques
vous êtes obligé de vous avez une petite
période comme ça de entre guillemets de
vacances d'un mois environ
mais a priori ça repart donc courant
février avec de nouveaux moyens des
métiers un peu plus nombreux avec dédé
des méthodes pédagogiques pour donner
envie aux jeunes de comprendre un métier
donc voilà donc ça fait partie du projet
de l'élargissement et du renforcement de
ce projet de développement économique
dans lequel la cité vite il sera toute
sa place et prenons à présent la
direction de villepreux le quartier des
eaux du moulin a été officiellement
inauguré aujourd'hui plus de 500
logements dont une centaine de logements
sociaux ont été construits
regardez ce reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et florent la mode
c'est officiel après deux ans de travaux
le quartier des eaux du moulin été
inauguré aujourd'hui
au total 520 logements sont sortis de
terre à l'est de la commune
la population de la ville passera donc
de 10000 à 11500 habitants selon le
maire les villes pro zients adhéré à ce
projet on leur a expliqué pendant
nombreux mois réunion publique
on était à l'écouté on leur a bien
montré ils ont vu là qu'est la qualité
du projet ils ont tout de suite adhéré
on n'a pas eu de recours parce qu'on a
vraiment ras de travailler d'une manière
efficace avec eux pour tous des mines et
pour leur expliquer qu'ils n'avaient pas
de problèmes que ça allait être un
projet qu'elle est très bien s'intégrer
dans notre ville et surtout conserver
l'identité de la commune c'était une
chose très importante pour eux parmi les
trente neuf mille mètres carrés
construit on retrouve des studios des
maisons d'une centaine de mètres carrés
mais également 160 logements sociaux on
a des obligations
on doit passer on est environ à 18% de 7
10% de l'agent sociaux doit atteindre
les 25% nous ne voulons pas d équipe
déséquilibrée la ville ce qui veut dire
construire éventuellement plus avec des
taux de logements sociaux moindre ce qui
permet de
respecter nos engagements concernant la
loi sru le quartier des eaux du moulin
n'est pas encore terminée un gymnase
devrait notamment voir le jour en 2018
est une école sera construite à
l'horizon 2020 et ce soir nous avons
parlé du renouveau de l'école troisième
pour cela nous accueillons en plateau
stéphane lamy responsable de la filière
cinéma audiovisuel bonsoir et françois
richer directeur communications de
l'école bonsoir admission merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors cette
semaine vous avez inauguré une nouvelle
annexe de votre école située à une
centaine de mètres du bâtiment
historique
ce lieu de 12 m² fait de troisième le
plus grand campus audiovisuel d'europe
et pour fêter l'événement le journaliste
et chroniqueur david abiker est venu
inaugurer la dernière pièce de l'édifice
un studio radio
il a ensuite participé à une émission
réalisée par les étudiants de l'école
nous reparlerons de 3e juste après ce
reportage réalisé par dany brillant
bienvenue dans ce studio puisque vous
l'inaugurer aussi donc j'espère que vous
en ferez bon usage
quoi de mieux que david habib coeur pour
donner vie à un studio radio
ce journaliste d'europe 1 a eu l'honneur
d'inaugurer le nouveau bâtiment de
l'école audiovisuel troisième surtout le
vrai plaisir c'est d'être avec les
étudiants et de voir à quel point ils se
sont donné du mal pour faire une
émission on retrouve des ambiances un
peu potache
ces insolents c'est rigolo on se plante
on recommence
voilà vive la vie quoi de beaux lots
grid autres à bâle voyant pour commencer
rejouera le prélude de bach que nous
avons laissé à la dernière leçon
chronique culturelle flash infos
interviewes les étudiants en journalisme
ont livré une émission radio d'une heure
trente un exercice pourtant pas évident
c'est dur quand on n'est pas en direct
et quand une émission est pas sous
tension de l'immédiat et de la nécessité
de faire de la bonne radio mais là on a
trouvé
je crois qu'il s'est installé un climat
qui était sympathique et pourtant il n'y
avait pas des millions d'auditeurs on
n'était pas en direct mais on était
ensemble avec ses douze mille mètres
carrés troisième est considéré comme le
plus grand campus audiovisuel d'europe
le chantier initié en 2013 a coûté plus
de 3 millions d'euros et met à
disposition des mille étudiants du
campus de nombreux moyens techniques on
a déjà un studio télé on a une salle de
projection fin de salles de cinéma de
300 places on a des studio de motion
capture et il nous manquait quelque
chose qui peut aider les journalistes à
prendre leur métier c'est un vrai studio
radio avec une régie un plateau pour
s'entraîner à ce métier là les
programmes enregistrés et m 24 heures
sur 24 sur la webradio de l'école que
l'on peut retrouver sur leur site ou sur
l'application mobile
alors nous voulons le voir dans les
images sans studio radio avec des locaux
à flambant neuf
une inauguration qui arrive après trois
ans de travaux vous avez investi
énormément dans cette école c'était une
nécessité de se renouveler comme ça oui
c'est une nécessité parce que le
bâtiment historique date de 1988 il nous
fallait absolument beaucoup plus d
espace plutôt qu'un espace locatif comme
tu dis qu'ils ont utilisés pour les
courts donc on a visité et trouver ce
bâtiment dès 2010 qui nous convenait
parfaitement parce qu'ils avaient des
plafonds à 7 m on avait des vraies
nécessité pour développer déjà au départ
la filière cinéma il nous fallait des
plateaux techniques et créer des
environnements de salles de cours et
travaux dirigés et il était
indispensable pour le développement
d'écoles par rapport à une nouvelle
filière que ce soit le spectacle vivant
que ce soit les le jeu vidéo avec
l'animation ou le journalisme
nous avions besoin vraiment de place
supplémentaire tout simplement
alors l'école à 28 ans à cette année
pour le pôle éducatif important de
territoire il ya un ancrage c'est
important c'est comme ça que vous
réussissez à attirer des élèves 300
élèves sortent chaque année justement un
troisième oui tout à fait alors on a
grosso modo dans l'école mille étudiants
en a 300 qui sont diplômés 300 qui
rentrent aujourd'hui on peut en
accueillir avec ces nouveaux bâtiments
justement jusqu'à 1400 l'objectif est de
développer de nouvelles filières qui
servent un petit peu sur la vague des
nouveautés technologiques comme le jeu
vidéo la motion capture comme ont abordé
à l'instant ou bien le journalisme qu'on
pourrait développer encore plus avec ce
nouveau studio radio qui vient clôturer
un petit peu la phase de travaux qui a
pris fin la fin fin 2015 alors le
secteur de l'audiovisuel c'est un
secteur économique compliqué on trouve
pas forcément facilement du travail
c'est un secteur qui attire toujours les
élèves sont aussi nombreux chaque année
alors on a beaucoup beaucoup de
candidats je m'occupe à la fois de la
communication et du recrutement des
étudiants donc je suis bien placé pour
voir que il ya une réelle demande de la
part des étudiants mais aussi des
inquiétudes de la part des parents
auxquels il faut répondre
ce qui est assez ce qui semble assez
évident c'est que il faut former les
étudiants sur le matériel qu'ils
retrouvent ensuite dans les mythes dans
les contextes professionnels et c'est
pour cela que nous basée à saint quentin
en yvelines
on nous on se permet d'investir
régulièrement sur du nouveau matériel
des caméras sur une motion capture en
studio radio pour pouvoir attirer ces
étudiants stéphane lamy la plupart des
étudiants vous optez de la fière cinéma
ils viennent pour le cinéma viennent
pour le journalisme viennent pour
technique de la fia riz cinéma reste
quand même pour l'instant la plus grosse
filière puisqu'on a des promotions d'à
peu près 180 étudiants par an mais comme
nous avons tout un système de sous
spécialisation finalement d'aller petit
effectif dans chaque spécialisation ça
reste elle qui attire
on va dire le plus un petit peu le coeur
hausse historique de l'école on a décidé
cette année de sortir la filière sont de
cette filière de manière à la rendre
autonome et aussi la rendre performante
et polyvalente beaucoup on a aussi
beaucoup de demandes pour le sont à
l'école
donc on a des sites est vraiment de
d'où aussi mettre mettre l'accent là
dessus après pour finir sur cette
question le la clé de l'emploi c'est
vraiment de coller aux besoins du métier
qui compliquait ou alors c'est pour ça
que activement on n'a pas du tout le
même effectif en journalisme qui ont
l'art au cinéma parce que notre objectif
c'était aussi cohérent avec
l'employabilité
on va pas recruter à tout va pour former
des chômeurs c'est pas du tout le but on
n'existerait plus de toute façon si
c'était le cas depuis longtemps
si vous êtes en compétition avec des
grosses écoles oui sur pareils à des
gros et coloriste qui sont reconnus mais
ces écoles de cinéma je pense que c'est
quand même compliqué oui mais on n'a pas
forcément le même positionnement
les grosses écoles concurrentes aussi
prennent des étudiants qui ont déjà un
bac + 2 partant pour un bac + 3 % des
cursus un petit peu supplémentaires et
ensuite il ya tellement métier dessous
métiers qui sont tous autant méconnu les
uns que les autres
il faut beaucoup de monde en fait pour
réaliser tous les films d'animation que
l'on voit toutes les émissions mais bon
journaliste bien énormément de métiers
différents
nous on a une on a une caractéristique
technique c'est à dire que nous les
journalistes que l'on forme sont
complètement opérationnels en images en
montage en sont en radio aussi donc on
ajoute en fait notre savoir faire
technique à ce type de formation
françois richet vous parliez tout à
l'heure
justement à des jeux vidéo mais aussi
peut-être du motion design la motion
capture ce sont des nouvelles stratégies
de développement pour l'école d'aller
vers ces métiers un petit peu voilà
technologique un peu futuriste
on a besoin d'avoir enregistré oui tout
à fait alors en fait la stratégie de
l'école pour compléter ce que disait
stéphane c'est vraiment de décidé de
surfer sur la vague des nouveautés
technologiques et de former les
étudiants plutôt sur la partie
opérationnelle sur la partie technique
aujourd'hui la motion capture toutes les
écoles ne peuvent pas se permettre
d'avoir la motion capture c'est le
c'est la technologie qui permet de
réaliser des films comme avatar
l'idée c'est de pouvoir animer des
personnages fictifs avec des acteurs
bien réel vous avez sûrement déjà venu
voir ses combinaisons avec les petits
capteurs exactement ça c'est la motion
capture ça demande énormément de besoins
en espaces en logiciels et en matériel
on a fait le pari de d'investir sur
cette technologie là pour former nos
étudiants pour qu'à la fin de leur
scolarité ils puissent rajouter sur leur
cv qu'ils ont cette possibilité de
travailler furent c'est sûr sur ces
métiers là qui ne sont peut-être pas
aujourd'hui commun dans tous les autres
écoles et c'est ça qui fait sûrement la
différence par rapport aux autres
idem pour le jeu vidéo et pour justement
parmi les techniques de tournage on l'a
vu dans le reportage mais aussi des
drones vous allez former des étudiants
pour voilà conduire des droits alors
aujourd'hui la réglementation est très
compréhensible et stricte elle va se
devrait se simplifier un petit peu pour
la partie professionnelle et non pas
pour les particuliers demain enfin
aujourd'hui on allume la télé on tombe
forcément sur des images aériennes ce
n'est plus des hélicoptères il faut
passer aux drones alors on voudrait
faire ce pari technologique de
s'associer éventuellement à une boîte de
formations pour former nos étudiants sur
le pilotage de drones et qu'ils aient
encore une fois cet avantage cet
avantage concurrentiel par rapport aux
autres étudiants diplômés en pouvant
avancer la possibilité de
de faire des images en drones c'est un
argument de vente comme un autre mais
quand on cherche du travail je pense que
tout compte
stéphane amis on l'avait donc dans le
reportage voilà les causes sont flambant
neuf le milieu de l'audiovisuel et
attire énormément les jeunes le monde de
la communication
quels conseils donneriez vous peut-être
qu'elle est mise en garde donneriez-vous
à des jeunes qui veulent travailler dans
ce métier ce que c'est un métier comme
les secteurs qui est difficile et qui
n'auraient peut être pas si facilement
le conseil s'est déjà de d'être vraiment
curieux et d'aller voir justement
d'aller observer des professionnels que
vous travaillez pour voir un petit peu
l'envers du décor et découvrir
l'ensemble des métiers est ce que c'est
vrai qu'ils sont très souvent attirés
par les métiers phares tout le monde
veut être réalisateur de longs métrages
etc mais mais personne n'est forcément
au fait des 250 postes qu'il y a qui
sont nécessaires à faire un film par
exemple
donc moi le conseil que je peux donner
ses jets se renseigner parce que là la
clé la réussite de ces métiers reste la
motivation la curiosité de manière à
pouvoir évoluer
technologie après technologie est aussi
d'un point de vue artistique parce que
l'on demande des tous les nouveaux
jeunes réalisateurs d'être inventifs que
ce soit à la télévision ou au cinéma
donc c'est peut-être la curiosité est
allé passer derrière le décor visitez
notre école bien sûr et puis allez vous
confronte à des professionnels demander
leur avis et quand on est motivé il ya
pas de raison il n'y a pas de raison
pour ne pas réussir tout le monde ne
sera pas forcément scorsese ou spielberg
mais pas donné la longue mais en tout
cas il ya beaucoup beaucoup de métier
beaucoup de demandes
on le voit avec nos téléphones aux
tablettes on veut des images de tous on
veut des émissions réalisées que ce soit
sur le web à la radio à la télévision
cinéma ton cas justement le web c'est
aussi un espace que vous allez un
vestiaire pour les étudiants le web
ferait partie des possibilités alors
aujourd'hui c'est le milieu qui est en
train de révolutionner le monde du jeu
vidéo avec tout ce qui est mobile
le monde de la télé des séries des web
séries de la radio des webradios
donc oui c'est ça aujourd'hui qui fait
partie de ce dynamisme et de ses
demandes au niveau des entreprises qui
sont à la recherche de nouveaux
collaborateurs
après sur la partie purement web c'est
pas ça fait pas partie de la stratégie
parce qu'on est vraiment orienté image
et son on essaye plutôt aujourd'hui de
se développer sur la partie sur les
métiers du jeu vidéo par exemple où il
ya encore peu de concurrence et beaucoup
de demandes de la part des entreprises
et la france est reconnue dans ce milieu
là donc on essaie de profiter de cette
opportunité
une dernière question avant de nous
quitter il va y avoir une nouveauté des
nouveautés en 2016 pour l'école
notamment au niveau des jeux vidéo alors
du coup il on profite là on a une
filière justement jeu vidéo qui
s'ouvrira la rentrée prochaine pour
faire très simple on s'est associé à une
école spécialisée dans le jeu vidéo qui
est basée à montpellier qui s'appelle
l'iufm 3d et donc on ouvre cette filière
jeu vidéo à la rentrée prochaine
et pour inaugurer cette filière on aura
donc le 26 janvier une invitée de marque
qui s'appelle kayane qui est une joueuse
professionnelle sponsorisée par red bull
et qui sera présente à l'école tout
l'après midi de 14h à 20h pour une
conférence est ensuite joué avec les
étudiants qui seront prêts à la défier
c'est un moyen de marquer
de manière un peu important de
l'ouverture de cette filière qui est
déjà très prometteuse parce qu'on a
quasiment 200 contacts d'étudiants
intéressés
ce qui n'était pas envisagé au début
donc on va devoir peut-être revoir à la
hausse les objectifs pour l'année
prochaine
mais c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour
nous et cette inauguration du 26 janvier
est une et une bonne première eh bien
merci beaucoup monsieur heures le
rendez-vous est notée si vous voulez en
savoir plus sachez qu'il ya des journées
portes ouvertes le 23 janvier et le 13
février
plus de renseignements sur le site
internet 3 i/s
les joyeux urbains est ce que vous
connaissez c'est un groupe qui a
commencé à trappes en 1994 cette année
ils fêtent leurs 20 ans d'existence pour
l'occasion il propose une tournée où ils
rejouent leurs plus grands succès le
groupe commence sa tournée anniversaire
sur la scène qui les a vu débuter ils
seront le 16 janvier à l'usiné à
chapeaux de rambouillet nous les avons
rencontrés regarder cette fois le
quatuor sera un quintette pour
l'anniversaire du groupe l'un des
fondateurs au monde sur scène les joyeux
urbains ont vingt ans et il se lance
dans une tournée de deux ans
le but de se réunir et de faire ce
spectacle déjà c'était de était de
s'amuser est en fête et de de reprendre
les chansons qu'on avait vraiment envie
de jouer sur scène
et voilà de construire un spectacle
autour de ce qu'on sait faire et on n'a
pas réfléchi
pas d'émotion plan des émotions telles
que le rire tels que la joie on souhaite
partager un moment un moment de bonheur
on souhaite partager l'argent des gens
globalement enfin si s'ils veulent bien
le partager avec nous en achetant
éventuellement notre intégral qui sera
pas cher pour cette tournée anniversaire
le groupe trappistes propose un best-of
20 ans de sel seulement première partie
des têtes raides de bénabar quatre
albums et des dizaines de titres non je
pense ne jamais lâcher le bout de gras
j'ai envie de dire on n'a jamais lâché
le côté mélange théâtre chanson même si
on ne sait mais à écrire des chansons
plus sérieuse on peut dire rapport au
début un peu moins des chansons un peu
plus sérieuse mais après on ça nous a
jamais empêché de garder le côté le côté
théâtral
leur tournée commence le 16 janvier à
l'usiné à chapeaux de rambouillet un
album intégral la compagne de quoi
découvrir redécouvrir leur style est là
ce n'est pas pour rire c'est votre
rendez vous habituel à nous recevons
comme chaque jeudi et notre journaliste
sportif aime qu elle elle me d'euros
pour sa chronique sport bonsoir moutons
alors florane aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter les rendez vous sportifs à ne
pas manquer à ce week-end dans le
département on prend tout de suite la
direction de la du tennis-club de la
verrière le 13e open de tennis de la
ville s'est ouvert ce week-end au parc
philippe cousteau pour cette édition
2016 150 joueurs venus principalement de
la ville nouvelle se sont inscrits pour
participer à la compétition
le tableau masculin compte 100 joueurs
âgés de 15 à 69 ans chez les dames une
cinquantaine de joueuses se sont
inscrits au tournant en écoute le
président du club et organisateur en
mauritanie
c'est souvent les secondes séries qui
viennent marquer des points pour être
pour être prof de tennis il faut
justement être seconde série et les
et enfin de les jeunes qui veulent
qu'ils souhaitent être professionnel
finalement et essayer de marquer des
points en début de saison
comme si le début de saison au mois de
janvier c'est bon à prendre
pour ce rendez vous un seul juge arbitre
officie pendant le tournoi le faire
payer donc indispensable pour le bon
fonctionnement de la compétition les
joueurs sautent aux arbitres c'est la
raison pour laquelle on demande aux
joueurs effectivement d'avoir d'être
sportifs de si la balle est faute ou
doit il ya jugement
on n'a juste pas sûr d'être faudra donc
on remet de balle voyez c'est ces deux
bonnes je fais confiance pas il ya la
lentille ne devrait pas exister
le week-end les premiers échanges débute
à 9 heures et se terminent à 20 heures
je vous rappelle que le tournoi se
clôture le dimanche 31 janvier après le
tennis on passe au monde de l'ovalie le
championnat de fédérale 3 reprend ses
droits ce week-end nicole ils vous ont
manqué pendant un mois surtout abou
floral et leishman les équipes fédérales
du département fouleront à nouveau les
pelouses ce week-end dans la poule une
plaisir à reçoit le leader du classement
reçoit le 4e dunkerque dimanche à 15
heures au stade robert barran les hommes
de jean miss doivent l'emporter pour
conserver la tête
il ne compte qu'un seul petit point
d'avancé sur le deuxième ris orangis son
dauphin la rencontre promet donc d'être
spectaculaire et on ne jouera pas
seulement à plaisir les versaillais
recevront également epernay ce week-end
décidément les fans de rugby seront
gâtés ce dimanche à pied en plus des
matches à enjeu on va on va pas se
plaindre un floral plaisir joue pour la
montée alors que versailles je lutte
pour sa survie dans ce championnat de
fédérale 3 les versaillais dernier du
classement reçoivent epernay ce dimanche
à 15 heures dans leur stade de
porchefontaine la rencontre semble
perdue d'avancé
epernay et troisième du championnat avec
écoutez moi bien florane à 21 points
d'avance sur versailles un gouffre c'est
énorme mais on ne sait jamais en rugby
les yvelinois peuvent toujours renversés
à la vapeur et on quitte à présent le
département des yvelines je vous emmène
en asie michael une étape de la coupe du
monde de cyclisme sur piste est
programmée à hong kong et des yvelinois
seront en course a donc vous le disiez
les épreuves de la coupe du monde se
dérouleront pour la première fois au
vélodrome de hong kong
les manches sont organisées ce samedi
dimanche plusieurs vignerons feront pas
de la délégation tricolore ils montrent
un françois pervis est en train de
s'imposer sur le keirin et la plaisir
aux 110 claire voudra terminer pour dans
les cinq premières sur les épreuves de
vitesse
un moyen de se relancer après une saison
en demi-teinte nous l'avons rencontré au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une grosse
période de fatigue avant donc voilà il
faut le temps de se remettre de tout ça
c'est c'est pas facile ça revient pas en
un claquement de doigts et on ça revient
pas non plus en deux entraînements donc
voilà je
je recommence à faire quelques chronos
et pas encore mes meilleurs chronos mais
ça remonte donc
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite les
coupes du monde c'est vraiment des
étapes
c'est important de ne pas les rater mais
il faut pas oublier que l'objectif
principal reste les mondiaux et cette
année les jeux aussi derrière je vous
rappelle florane que cette épreuve peut
permettre à 110 claire d'engranger des
points en vue de sa qualification pour
les jeux olympiques de rio à l'été
prochain
on lui souhaite de se qualifier merci
beaucoup michael on vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour votre émission 17,8 sport
mais également demain pour le 7 8 e
week-end je suis sur tous les fronts
vous êtes tous répondent bon courage
pour votre préparation pour ces deux
émissions c'est la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
demain vous retrouvez wilfried errishi
pour l'essentiel de l'actu quant à moi
je veux retrouver lundi pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une très bonne soirée
également un bon week-end